[Musique]
c'est la fin idéale
j'ai craint son journal pour lire l ol
j'espère qu'elles seront sociaux tels
voyages grande porte avant la débâcle du
bav son coup si des petits commérages eu
de très grosses auteur est le petit écho
de la forêt c'est très vrai il y à
toutes les informations à chaque
nouvelle édition on n'a jamais de
déception
ça vous le découvrirez dans le cul des
cours de l'offre
[Musique]
[Rires]
voyons voyons voyons quelles sont les
dernières nouvelles au tiens tiens tiens
mademoiselle de la cigogne est parti en
voyage
les vieux bien au maximum ainsi que
szavay 6 av
qu'est ce qui t'arrive dans ce cas je
suis je suis essoufflée et pourquoi
parce que j'ai couru comme une folle
pourquoi
sais tu ce que j'apprends et a pris de
talent et tu a augmenté non elle est
partie quitte à l'étude mademoiselle de
lacie coat l'afld ravages mathom du bec
merci max que spatule mademoiselle de la
cigogne est parti décidément la nouvelle
faisait de l'effet à tout le monde
cependant obtient pierre club
bah ouais tel parti au maroc d'un
village
non elle a dû aller voir sa famille en
alsace et rocco et c'est à dire qu elle
aurait pu nous plaisent il y est les
grands pas elles ce sont 6 de personnes
le bloc gauche quand le teil hounsou
portable ou par là aussi du départ de
mademoiselle de la cigogne chez les
frères k stores ça va nous reposer un
peu car à un peu fatigante en plus et
les d'un snuff on croirait qu'à kehl aux
morts en votant qu'elle paraît mémo pire
club on allonger la liste des défauts de
cette pauvre cigognes jamais content que
mon p'tit bal coléreuse gourmande bain
et vous mêmes des synthés et entend les
terres l'énumération des défauts de
mademoiselle de la cigogne continue mais
aussi chez les frères castor est jalouse
et vexant contraria basse mais vous dis
une bonne chose il a très bien fait
partir les jours passèrent et
mademoiselle de la cigogne ne revenait
pas un poulet quand même de donner de
ses nouvelles
c'est tout et
elle s'en va sans dire où elle va elle
nous laisse dans l'inquiétude
l'inquiétude que nous luttons change a
très vite parmi nos amis de la forêt
avaient fois les fermes et maisons
mademoiselle cigognes lourdes matt russe
et ses nuits était arrivé un accident
comme au zoo je ne sais pas pendant son
voyage elle s'est peut-être cassé une
aile ou une patte
il faut nous avoue une source cette
maudite simone commence à nous moquer y
peu à peu on commence à évoquer les
beaux souvenirs
j'aimais bien la voir le matin qu'elle
faisait son jogging
elle avait beaucoup d'élégance il faut
dire qu'elle sait c'est adele et puis
elle a beau connaissent pareilles et
puis à l'heure les roses et puis à la
banque du plus humble beaucoup service
on peut tout lui demander elle râle pour
la forme parce qu'elle est timide et
alka sa timidité sceau des grands airs
les adore alors moi je vais vous dire un
sans elle notre forêt n'est plus la même
quel homme si colin personnalité eh bien
ça a piqué les pactes et je me sens tout
triste
dieu n'est plus bon ménage je ne
travaille plus
manon plus moi plus joueur encore du
haut doubs
et bien moi je fais un lecteur je ne
mangerai plus de l'étude tant que
mademoiselle de la cigogne ne sera pas
revenu
foire mais oui cher téléphone on dit que
les absents ont toujours tort vous voyez
bien qu'il n'en est rien en tout cas à
bientôt pour une nouvelle édition du
petit et trop de la forêt